Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Denise RQ
Essendo madre di sei figli,
negli ultimi 28 anni
ho dovuto farmi ripetutamente
una serie di domande.
La prima è stata: ma il mio comportamento
nei loro confronti
è eticamente, affettivamente,
psicologicamente corretto?
Perché, appunto, avevo
delle grandi responsabilità educative.
La seconda era: ma io continuo
ad essere affettivamente allineata
con la persona che volevo essere,
con la bambina che ero?
Perché anch'io sono stata una bambina,
esattamente come i miei figli
e quindi avevo bisogno
di essere allineata con quello
che erano i miei desideri,
con quello che volevo fare
e io ero certa di una cosa,
che volevo fare la maestra,
perché io volevo continuare
a parlare coi bambini,
a relazionarmi coi bambini
e l'aspetto educativo, l'aspetto
formativo è stato sempre, per me,
un chiodo, un chiodo fisso nella mia vita.
Io sono del 1959, sono nata
a Torino, in questa foto ho sei anni
e la mia mamma lavorava,
cinquant'anni fa la mia mamma
- siamo tre sorelle e un fratello -
lavorava, assolutamente per me
era normale vederla lavorare.
La mamma seguiva
delle attività commerciali
che avevamo a Torino, mentre mio padre
faceva il pendolare
tra il Veneto e il Piemonte,
dove avevamo delle attività industriali.
Un ricordo preciso che ho
di mia mamma è questo.
Noi abitavamo in una palazzina
al settimo piano
e sotto c'erano
gli uffici dove lei lavorava.
Lei era manager,
gestiva queste attività commerciali
e la cosa che io ricordo
con estremo piacere,
era appena nata
la mia sorellina più piccola,
c'era la signora
che ci accudiva e mi diceva:
"Maria Cristina, alza la persiana,
che la mamma giù negli uffici
vede e capisce
che la sorellina si è svegliata
e così sale ad allattarla".
Quindi c'era questa condivisione,
esisteva, c'era, no,
tra il lavoro e la famiglia
e quindi per me
il fatto di avere dei figli e di lavorare
è stato assolutamente normale.
Ma c'è un altro punto
che è stato estremamente
formativo, nella mia vita
privata e professionale.
Questo è il mio papà. In questa foto
il mio papà aveva circa vent'anni
ed è stata scattata in un campo
di concentramento in Germania.
Come dire, a vent'anni
lui non si chiamava più Carlo Gribaudi,
ma si chiamava 3B309873.
Gli avevano tolto la dignità.
Oltre la dignità gli avevano tolto, però,
tutti i sogni
che i ragazzi di vent'anni hanno.
Quindi c'era questa esperienza
molto forte della mia vita,
perché mio papà era militare a Torino,
stava facendo il servizio militare
e in un giorno
viene caricato in un carro bestiame,
viene deportato e rimarrà due anni.
Ma la cosa fondamentale
che mio padre è riuscito
a trasmettermi da questa esperienza
estremamente dolorosa e negativa
è il saper fare, perché uno
dei punti di forza di mio padre,
al quale gli era stata tolta
la dignità era che lui,
nei momenti liberi dagli studi,
scendeva nella bottega del papà
e imparava l'arte dell'artigiano.
Lui sapeva usare gli utensili,
come la chiave a stella
e questa cosa qua diventò
talmente importante nella sua vita,
nel suo periodo di permanenza in Germania
- lui non amava chiamarlo
campo di concentramento,
lo chiamava periodo di permanenza
perché aveva compreso
che doveva togliere la negatività
legato a questo
per elaborare questa esperienza -
e quindi lui era, al momento,
quando chiesero
"Ma chi è che sa fare
la manutenzione delle cucine,
di qualsiasi cosa", lui rispose "Io"
e questa cosa qua,
in qualche modo gli salvò la vita,
gli restituì quella parte di dignità
che gli era stata tolta.
Quindi questo è un altro pezzo
della mia vita importante,
perché quello che sono io ora
è il frutto di quello che sono stata, è un
passaggio nel quale è attraversata
la mia famiglia, mio padre, mio padre
E poi va beh, c'è un momento importante.
Qua ci sono i miei sei figli,
me l'hanno concessa,
ho chiesto, perché
per il diritto alla privacy...
Ho dovuto farlo.
Siamo in California, è il 1998,
vanno dai 5 ai 13 anni,
nella foto c'è
- mi piace dirlo perché mi piace
chiamarli per nome -
Carlo, Giulio, Elena, Alessandro,
Giacomo e Maria Cristina.
Loro avevano le idee molto chiare nel '98,
io un po' meno, perché loro
volevano fare surf.
E..insomma, fare surf,
per chi lo ha praticato, non è facile,
ci sono delle regole precise.
Poi questi erano bambini nati in Italia,
quindi l'oceano californiano,
le onde, non è una cosa semplice, no?
Quindi c'erano delle regole precise,
avevamo delle regole precise.
C'erano le regole generali, che sono
devi stare sempre molto attento
a chi sta davanti a te,
a chi sta dietro, di fianco,
perché quando si prende
l'onda potresti tu travolgere
chi sta dietro o potresti essere
travolto da chi sta davanti a te,
quindi c'erano queste
regole di comportamento.
Poi invece c'erano le regole
che dava la mamma.
La mamma, ovviamente, stava tutto il tempo
che loro stavano in acqua
sotto la torretta della Life Guard
col cannocchiale, perché io
non mi fidavo della Life Guard,
nessuno avrebbe guardato meglio
i figli di me, quindi stavo là.
Le regole quali erano?
Sei bambini, 5-13 anni,
bisogna entrare in acqua solo in coppia.
Bisogna anche - c'erano poi
4 maschi e 2 femmine,
quindi dovevano accettare
anche di essere un gruppo misto.
Nel caso di difficoltá
- lo sto dicendo davanti
ad una delle mie figlie che mi dice
sì sì, è vero, conferma tutto,
quindi è proprio vero -
dovevano assolutamente darsi delle regole.
Se uno di loro stava male
o non se la sentiva più, dovevano uscire.
Io non so se all'epoca
mi resi conto di quello
che stavo dicendo
da un punto di vista educativo,
ma è stata una cosa dirompente,
perché prima di tutto,
non tanto con le parole,
ma di nuovo esattamente quel saper fare,
no? che è importante,
quel saper fare legato proprio
alla vita di mio padre, ancora una volta
non parole ma passiamo ai fatti.
Pensate che tutt'ora,
a distanza di quindici anni,
loro vivono e lavorano
e studiano in giro per il mondo,
ancora adesso,
sia nella loro vita professionale
che nella loro vita affettiva,
nel momento del bisogno
loro cavalcano ancora l'onda insieme,
sono ancora lì che si chiamano.
Magari uno sta in Cina,
l'altro sta in America,
ma la voglia, il desiderio
di stare insieme,
quindi sono tutti valori
di condivisione, no,
da un esempio proprio pratico, quotidiano,
a distanza di quindici anni ancora emerge.
Però cavalcare l'onda
è un altro grande insegnamento,
perché cosa succede? tu ti metti lì,
intanto devi avere molta pazienza.
Loro erano bambini,
la pazienza di arrivare a prendere l'onda,
di prendere l'onda giusta.
Ma l'onda è come il successo, lo cavalchi
ma non stai tutta la vita sull'onda,
quindi non stai tutta la vita
sul successo.
Dal successo cadi,
quindi devi saperti rialzare
e poi decidere che di nuovo
nuoti controcorrente
e vai ad affrontare l'altra onda.
Questo è stato
un esercizio mentale pazzesco
oltre che un esercizio fisico,
perché è vero, il successo
è come la bellezza, passa,
non dura mica per sempre...
Quindi quello che resta
è come noi ci formiamo,
è come noi affrontiamo giorno dopo giorno.
Una cosa sulla quale mi sono
sempre sperimentata è la resilienza.
Io ho cominciato a correre,
non ho mai smesso
e non ho più smesso dall'età di 14 anni,
ne ho 54 e sono quarant'anni che corro.
Corro perché mi piace correre,
perché mi dà una sensazione di libertà,
mi permette di pensare,
mi permette di mettere in moto
tutta una serie di adrenaline,
però se voi mi chiedete
"ma qual è la maratona, la meno
faticosa, la più bella di tutte?"
io non vi racconterò mai la meno faticosa,
ma immediatamente vi racconto,
mi verrebbe da dire,
la maratona di Atene del 2010,
erano 2500 anni,
era l'anniversario della prima maratona,
maratona durissima,
5 chilometri in pianura, 30 in salita
e gli ultimi 5 in discesa.
Una sciatalgia mi ha distrutto
al trentesimo chilometro,
io non ce la facevo più ad andare avanti.
C'era un servizio d'ordine pazzesco,
sarebbe bastato fare così con la manina
per farsi portare via,
perché ne portavano via tanti.
Io la mano non l'ho alzata,
perché io ho deciso
di caricarmi sulle spalle,
oltre la sciatalgia, pure la resilienza
e gli ho detto: io e te adesso
arriviamo alla fine,
perché io non posso
non arrivare alla fine.
Strisciando ci sono arrivata.
Credo che questa
sia davvero la differenza.
Mi piace anche passare
questo messaggio oggi.
Io ringrazio veramente tutti
perché i giovani che ho visto oggi,
l'accoglienza, i giovani,
questa energia positiva
che giorno dopo giorno
continuo a ricevere,
per me è importantissima.
Qui c'è una foto,
perché in azienda da noi
tutti questi valori che io
vi ho raccontato della mia vita,
ovviamente, come tutti voi,
io faccio fatica a dividere
il privato dal professionale.
Io quello che sono
nella mia vita privata -
non riesco a mettere
una maschera e cambiare,
lo sono anche nella mia
vita professionale.
Quindi la condivisione
dei valori, l'umanità.
Mio padre
lo ricordano tutti, tutti dicono
che sia stato un grande imprenditore,
un imprenditore visionario.
Negli anni Settanta mio padre
è stata una persona
che lo consideravano...
Le sue aziende erano veramente
degli incubatori di idee,
ma la stragrande maggioranza
delle persone lo ricorda per l'umanità.
Qualcuno gli aveva tolto
e lui aveva deciso di restituire
creando in continuazione posti di lavoro.
Io non posso non prendere questi messaggi
e non portarli nell'azienda dove lavoro,
quindi lo spirito di appartenenza
è talmente forte
nella nostra azienda,
che batte la bandiera dei pirati,
perché noi siamo convinti
di essere dei pirati
che andiamo alla conquista
di nuovi mercati.
Questa è una foto di qualche mio collega.
Adesso, qua ci sono io,
io in questo momento
sono amministratrice unica
di un'azienda metalmeccanica,
che ha radici lontane, è un
family business, ha 250 anni di storia.
Per sei generazioni
ci sono sempre stati uomini,
per la prima volta
c'è una donna che gestisce
l'azienda metalmeccanica.
Però abbiamo deciso di fare
un passaggio ulteriore,
perché è importante dare un buon esempio
e cercare di comprendere
che la leadership va condivisa.
Allora io e mio marito Massimo
ci alterniamo
da oltre dodici anni,
di tre anni in tre anni,
nel ruolo di amministratore,
perché la differenza di genere
fa la differenza, soprattutto
nelle aziende metalmeccaniche
che hanno sempre parlato al maschile.
Quindi provate a pensare,
per cinque generazioni
erano fabbri che forgiavano
il ferro nelle fucine,
dalla sesta generazione
è diventata invece,
ha deciso di diventare
un'attività, si è deciso
che diventasse un'attività industriale
e quindi negli anni
quest'azienda metalmeccanica,
dal ferro è passata a governare
tecnologie come quella meccanica,
elettronica, digitale,
come la computing science,
quindi siamo entrati
e costringendo la sottoscritta
e quindi sempre dovendo alzare
l'asticella giorno dopo giorno,
in tecnologie che prima ci erano oscure.
Quindi il mio passato è servito
e serve tutt'ora,
perché lo ritengo
estremamente corretto restituire,
dobbiamo restituire,
soprattutto la mia generazione,
quelli dai capelli bianchi come me,
a parte la tinta, voglio dire,
è fondamentale che restituiamo all'Italia
e soprattutto che diamo
un momento di grande positività
e far credere ai giovani
che effettivamente ci sono aziende,
ci sono posti di lavoro
dove noi abbiamo bisogno di loro.
Tutto il tempo che ho libero
lo dedico ai giovani:
lavoro insieme alle associazioni,
alla regione, alle Università,
perché siamo noi che abbiamo
più bisogno di loro che loro di noi.
Quindi 3+3, ve l'ho detto,
di me e di mio marito.
Concludo dicendo questa cosa qua.
La curiosità per tutto ciò che non conosco
e l'amore per la vita mi hanno costretta
giorno dopo giorno
ad alzare l'asticella,
ma la cosa più bella,
la sensazione più bella
è che ogni giorno cerco
di essere una donna migliore di quella
che ero il giorno precedente.
Grazie. (Applausi)